night over to you yes sally first i want
to say you know a lot of people ask what
does this mean when there's one of these
storm warnings a dust storm warnings not
just be careful out on the roads it's
also
be careful going outside if you have
trouble breathing what exactly does that
mean what group what's a sensitive group
you hear that all the time so we're
talking about the elderly people who
have respiratory diseases if you're
watching and you have one you know you
have it if you have asthma something
like that also a good reminder for
everybody keep your doors in your
windows closed you don't want that dust
to come
inside this is sort of what we're
dealing with this was tweeted out by the
county earlier today i sort of uh say
when we see pictures like this it looks
more like mars than las vegas but you
just got to be careful out there because
all that stuff is going to end up if
you're in your lungs if you're not
careful let's talk about these power
outages right now it's actually down
about 300 customers than we saw about a
half hour ago and right now here in
southern nevada we're about 210
customers affected so that's not a very
large group of people but of course
we'll keep you posted as the afternoon
goes on and just stay safe out there
here